there's a rookie wide receiver in the
NFL right now that is dominating and
unless you're big into fantasy football
you probably don't know these three
things about him he's leading the league
in catches right now like he has more
receptions than Justin Jefferson Tyree
kill and Stefan Diggs and he's second in
the league for receiving yards only
behind Jay jetters and the craziest part
is there were 19 other receivers drafted
before him in the NFL draft last year so
who is this rookie Phenom his name is
puka nakua and he's already smashed two
NFL rookie records in his first season
with the Rams he broke the rookie record
for most receptions in the game with 15.
he even broke Odell Beckham's record for
most catches in his first two games with
25. so how did a talent like puka fall
all the way to the fifth round in the
NFL draft injuries he initially played
at University of Washington but broke
his foot in his freshman year he
transferred to BYU but also dealt with
ankle injuries but he ended up getting
drafted by the Rams and with pooping cup
out with a hamstring injury he's been
the perfect fit in Sean mcveigh's
offense